blm activist kim brown i wanted to play
this clip for you as well um
she's on a i think this is her own show
which yeah okay this is called burn it
the name of her podcast or show or
youtube show whatever it is it's called
burn it down so you kind of get an idea
of where she's coming from
and here's what she had to say making an
eloquent case in favor of rioting and
looting let's listen to that
i support all that i support them
looting
the the dollar tree i support the
looting
of uh what other they loot uh like the
like the advanced auto parts
um i remember last year they looted
target i support audit
loot audit do you know why because black
people
and marginalized and oppressed people
could loot
every store in his whole country for 200
years it would not even come close to
the debt
that america owes us okay
yeah um so that that is full-throated
defense of rioting and looting
we hear that all the time from blm
activists
this is not shocking at all it's not
just that they're doing it but they
support it in principle and will
explicitly defend it
and will do so publicly without apology
and yet we're still told that the blm
movement is mostly peaceful
so peaceful movement the fact that
they're both looting and writing and
defending it and encouraging it and
saying do it more
uh yeah you're not supposed to hear that
let's just ignore that part
of course that what she just what she
said there uh is
wrong on so many levels and you we we we
could spend all day
uh dissecting it and and tearing it
apart but
let's start with one really basic thing
here
that she claims that she is owed a debt
from america
she's wrong about that can we
america doesn't owe you anything
whatever your race is you're not you're
not owed anything simply for existing
okay we're not we're not in debt to you
society is not in debt to you
and again i don't care what your race is
society is not in debt to you
and but if you live like that with that
kind of mentality then this is what you
end up with and if enough people
live like that with that mentality you
end up with rioting and looting
but even if america did in in some
mysterious way
uh collectively owe you a debt
why are you taking out taking it out on
the dollar tree or auto zone
how do they owe it to you the people who
work there
many of them minorities that
so you're you're taking it this this
debt that you think really
white america owes you you're taking it
out on your own
community
the dollar tree in minneapolis that's
not white america that you're that
you're tearing down it's not capitalism
that you're tearing down
it is your own community that you're
victimizing
people in your community work there
people in your community depend on that
place they go and they shop there
you you tore it apart and burned it down
so even on your own logic it doesn't
make any sense
but there really is no logic at all so
at the end of the day it's simply
destruction for destruction's case and
um
and for looters yeah the the motivation
for most looters of
of of all stripes is simply i could get
free stuff and i want free stuff
it does doesn't go much it doesn't get
much deeper than that i think for the
average
looter listen hit that subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated